all right so i just finished my round
three game against bador joe bava
uh which i'm sure is a name that a lot
of people are familiar with uh the the
creator and savior of the jobava london
before i get into the game i want to
share a photo from
just a couple days ago
this was uh our lunch table this is joe
bava right here
and actually the reason why i played joe
bava in round three
was that he lost to irene sukundar a
good friend of mine
in the second round today
um or the the earlier round today i
should say
and uh yeah she won a nice game against
him so we were both one out of two going
into round three
and um i was excited for this match up
because i've never played joe bava over
the board i think i've played him maybe
a few times online
and
he's a very interesting player like
plays a lot of uh a lot of different
openings
i wasn't entirely sure what to expect
um i i was really tempted to play the
joe bava london with d4 knight c3 bishop
f4
but i thought it's probably not the best
practical choice against someone like
him
um so i decided this game to play pawn
e4
and uh
deviate from my first round game where
which i just played in london
i was actually expecting him to go into
like a caro khan
or sicilian or petrov
but he
surprised me a little bit on move one by
going for a pierce
and this actually transposed after uh
d496 knight c3 pawn e5 uh this is now a
philidor's defense
and i'm pretty sure lee chess calls this
the the lion
yeah the lion variation
which
i think has a relatively
solid reputation maybe a little bit
passive
and this is a line that uh
i encounter a lot on online blitz
because black has a very natural
development even though black is also a
little bit short on space
so game continued from here bishop d4
bishop b7
all of these moves uh were pretty
standard opening theory
um yeah pawn a4 pawn a5
now i should note here that um
the reason for playing a4 is just to
grab space on the queen side and one of
the positional threats is to put the
pawn 95 and grab even more space
so if he plays a move like c6 then a5 i
think is a decently strong move
so pawn a5 prevents me from playing a5
and we continue h3 rook e8 bishop b3
and bishop f8 and uh yeah so far
everything is very normal
and here i played an idea that
i usually like to play in online blitz
it's a little bit of a
tricky move is queen to b1 uh now i
should note the standard move is queen
d2
and he was actually telling me after the
game that he was
uh i guess a little bit more
fearful of this move given that uh it's
perhaps uh the best move objectively and
uh it's one of the reasons why this line
isn't so popular um i think he was
telling me like he was going to play c6
rook d1 knight b6
um
but still very much be a game
so i chose to play queen b1 because it
leads to
also a simple ideas to play queen a2
and create the battery against f7 pawn
now he takes i take back and he plays
knight e5
so the position transforms a little bit
in the center
and here i had a decision to make
whether to
take with the knight or the bishop or
maybe even a move like bishop e2 and i
decided to take with a bishop and even
though this concedes the bishop pair i
thought
i just have a very stable solid position
also with some initiative
not only am i attacking f7 but rook t1
is also coming with tempo
so
i wasn't feeling too bad around here
he defends queen e7 brook d1
c6
and
yeah so far i think it was like very
standard chess
and uh all my pieces are
developed and it was a question what to
do next and i decided to go for a very
typical plan is knight h4
buying the f5 square for the knight but
also eyeing the g6 square this is a
a potentially tricky idea that uh
because f pawn is pinned
to the king knight g6 is possibly a
positional threat to uh
eventually get black starks for a bishop
so he plays queen c7 removing the queen
from being a potential target
i play rook e3
still trying to optimize the pieces
maybe some ideas of rook lifting but
also ideas of just doubling up on d-file
he plays bishop b6
and i play rook d3 king h7
and in this position
i'm
sorry to say that uh i just
completely overlooked
a crucial idea in the position and my
next move turned out to be uh really
really really bad
even though when i played this move i
thought
it was a decently
good move
um but the move is not at five
and at first this looks natural
uh just improving the knight and eyeing
the d6 square
and when i played this move i was mainly
considering what would happen after
knight takes e4
as calculating an interesting line
bishop takes e6
i should note that if i take the knight
back then black ends up winning a pawn
so i was gonna take here first and
um i guess black has two options here
if pawn takes i take here takes and then
here
with ideas of knight f6 coming also
hitting the queen so this would be very
good for white
and the main line that i was considering
was
that take c3
after which i can take back with pawn
and even though i'm down upon
in this position
i think white just has a lot of
initiative
so i was going down the rabbit hole of
these lines
and
i didn't quite realize a danger in a
different line
yeah he ended up
not taking on e4 but taking on f5 and
this turns out to be really problematic
for me because after pandex f5
pawnee 4 is played
and i considered this uh
when i played knight f5 and i thought
okay i can just play rook e3 and target
the now possibly overextended pawn and
e4 and i thought okay i'll just double
up
and the pawn should be a weakness on top
of that
f7 is uh is just hanging here
so i saw this position from a distance
and thought it wasn't so bad
the thing that i missed is black just
has e3 coming
and
if i play rook e3 there's bishop c5
and it turns out to be
just really really
bad for white like white's whole
position can crumble very quickly
now i didn't play rook e3 and maybe i
should have uh even though after like
rookie one
pawnee three
it doesn't look so great for white
um instead i played rook t2 still
allowing pawn e3 and after he takes
he plays bishop c5
and
even though i'm temporarily up a pawn
and i can win
the pawn on f7
uh
when bishop takes e3 comes my king is
going to be running out of squares
especially because the dark spurs are
weak the queen is piercing through the
position
so i decided first to play king h1 here
getting off the diagonal of the bishop
he takes with a rook on e3
and then i took on f7
and then in this position
joe bava unleashes
a really crazy move that i did not see
coming and even after he played this
move
it took me
maybe a few minutes to fully understand
what was going on
he played knight g4
uh before he played this i thought
things were still like under control
because i was preventing knight h5 i was
preventing knight e4
but knight g4
is uh
just an insane
idea
which
leads to a really cool mating line
um
i i really don't have too many options
after this move because black is
fretting made in one
so
uh yeah it looks like i have to take the
knight and then
black sacrifices
more material here
and uh maybe if if you're watching and
you want to try and find the move
feel free to pause the video but this is
black to move sack more material and i'm
pretty sure it's just force mate for
black
so uh
yeah good luck finding the next move
that joe bava uncorked
the brilliant rook to e1
and yeah i i felt a pit in my stomach at
this point
uh realizing that he had just calculated
like everything else
and uh on top of that oh a small crowd
was forming around our table
uh because he he was in the midst of
sacrificing two pieces first a knight
than a rook
and even though i'm up a ton of material
here after queen to g3
there's just no defending against the
force mate
queen h4s and mate threats
and my pieces are just not in shape to
defend against uh
against the combination of the queen and
the bishop
so i thought for for several minutes
here just searching for any
any last opportunity
i do have a couple spike checks
but they don't really do anything
so i played the move rook d3
unfortunately this doesn't really help
because after queen h4 white is still
getting mated
and i resigned in this position
just to show how things could play out
if rook h3
there's queen takes e1 king h2 bishop g1
king h1 a small windmill and then queen
g1 would be made
so really nice game a really nice finish
by joe bava
to uh completely punish my uh my kind of
careless blunder
with knight f5 and i i think um
unfortunately this game it was really
determined by
by one blunder um
i have not checked things with the
engine but
we chatted a little bit after the game
and uh
yeah i think in this position
ah maybe white is slightly slightly
worse but uh okay it definitely could
have gone on probably should have taken
the bishop
and um i'd consider this actually during
the game rook takes e6
uh the knight should really probably
just return to f3
um or maybe here i can play that f5
so earlier did i have any any advantage
no engine already prefers back in this
position
if we go back even further
ah the engine wants knight takes e5
yeah i guess maybe i should have valued
the bishop pair
a little bit more and then play bishop
e3
probably close to equal here
and maybe one takeaway from this game is
i should make an effort to
actually understand the main line
uh queen d2
which i think is a more standard move in
this position
uh just preparing the simple rook d1
and perhaps if the queen uh
is is just more in the center than
uh then i wouldn't get brutally mated as
what happened in the game
so anyway this was a a quick and kind of
painful game but i hope it inspires
people watching
that
yeah joe bava is just a monster when it
comes to attacking and just concrete
calculation kudos to him for finding a
brilliant finish
and uh and yeah this was the only
day of the tournament
with two games a day
so tomorrow there's just one game a day
if you want to watch live i will leave a
link to the live broadcast in the video
description i'm pretty sure tomorrow's
round is at 5 p.m
uh abu dhabi time so stay tuned and uh
again thanks everyone for
all your support and uh and comments in
the previous videos i do really
appreciate the positivity so yeah stay
tuned for more chess and i'll see you
guys in the next video